we on the organizing committee have some
hopes for you today we hope that you
enjoy learning new things and about new
tools from the talks that you meet great
folks maybe even the person next to you
right now and say hi and meet new people
and that you've come away empowered and
inspired with new tools and new ideas
and so we hope you have a great time at
the rest of the conference and without
further ado I'm going to introduce our
first keynote speaker
Andrea Trevino leads the data team for
League of Legends
at Riot Games which is one of the most
played games in the world
before joining riot she was the director
of data science for data science comm
and she brings the perspective from her
backgrounds in healthcare ad tech
digital media ecommerce and her PhD work
in electrical and computer engineering
from the University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign and as well as her work
at research work at the MIT Lincoln
Laboratory the MIT Institute for
learning and memory and the Boys Town
National Research Hospital so please
join me in welcoming Andrea all right
good morning everyone thank you for that
wonderful introduction I would also like
to thank the organizers for inviting me
to be here today and putting together
this wonderful conference so without
further ado I'll go ahead and get
started I've already gotten a great
introduction so I don't need to go over
it again but yeah I lead the team for
League of Legends at Riot Games I wanted
to start the talk with one of the
questions that I get most often which is
how did you get into big data and data
science personally and what I wanted to
get across this morning was that there
is no one path every single person has a
completely different path and this is
just my path into that process and the
path that I followed is that I didn't
start in big data into a data analytics
what I started with was in the 90s
I thought robots video games and coding
was cool and I went with that so back
then I was more interested in coding and
understanding circuits and understanding
the systems that worked in place back
then data science wasn't really no
well-known in pop culture but there were
elements of it starting to believe
into the public consciousness all the
way back as the Terminator which was
already talking about his neural net
processing system when I went into
research my I took a wavy path in terms
of my route to the ultimate data science
I started in high energy physics then
went into wireless communications brief
stint in brain machine interfaces then
actually modeling how neural processes
would respond and finally perception and
automatic speech recognition while I was
going through this path as was mentioned
before the the business and industry
world was starting to discover more and
more about data so in the early 2000s
everyone in industry realized that
collecting big data was absolutely vital
to understanding their business and
their success and then around the year
2008 is when data science was ultimately
coined and start to became started to
become a thing where industry realized
that they could take all of this data
that they had aggregated start adding in
some algorithms that had been existing
for years and years before in research
and science and creating this new field
where you combine business understanding
and data modeling in order to build a
competitive advantage so now where we're
at is that data science is a key part of
every single industry you'll see data
science in public policy in retail in
automotive in the entertainment industry
we have Netflix here in town they have a
giant data science department you see it
in healthcare in transportation and the
one that I'm involved in right now is
data science and gaming so I'm at Riot
Games to give a quick introduction to
Riot Games the company we're located
here in Los Angeles we are the developer
and publisher of the game League of
Legends and winner of our key cultural
values is putting the player experience
first so the game itself was launched in
2009 which is a long
ago in the data world it's a
team-oriented player-versus-player game
where you play as a team of five against
another team of five we have over a
hundred champions that a player can
choose from when they actually jump in
and decide to join the game and we're
set in a modern fantasy world so in the
splash out here you'll see there's a
scarecrow there's like a little girl
with an angry teddy bear a mage it's
just a whole giant world of
possibilities I wanted to start by
introducing the actual game itself so
that you can start thinking about the
complexity of the space and what it
would do in terms of data science
problems so this is the actual map that
you play this type of game on the way
that it works is it split into two
halves you have a red half in a blue
half you try to control the world and
have five people on your team to help
you there's three lanes through which
players will play you can think of this
really like a physical sports game and
actually league of legends was one of
the first games that introduced and
popularized eSports as a category so
then you have players take different
positions within those different lanes
so these are four of the five champions
that you would play and then you have
one more to roam so these are the
fundamental rules of the game if you
think of like football or basketball
these are the different positions that
you can play and understanding how you
would approach data science problems in
order to understand that well you need
to think about actually understanding
the game itself there's a number of
objectives you can take on the board and
then you win by seizing your opponent's
objective so that is the high-level
picture of the game but let's start to
think about this as data practitioners
so what kinds of problems are being
introduced within this ecosystem well I
mentioned that a player has to pick one
individual champion we actually have
over a hundred and forty champions
that a player can pick from and each
individual one has a completely
different set of powers that are
available to a player when the person
chooses this individual champion they
will be playing with them from 20 to 50
minutes solid so going through all 140
plus would be a major time investment
for an individual play player another
and another source of complexity is that
we have major releases for the game
internationally every two weeks and what
I mean by major releases is that we can
release content we might release new
champions so if you think about this in
terms of sports
it's like introducing a new type of
player to the field and seeing what
happens for the game we introduce new
maps we have events these are major
changes to what is possible within the
space of the game and these patches and
releases have been happening every two
weeks almost since 2009 itself we also
release completely different Maps
so it's like you're changing the field
or the court in which the play is
happening and finally we have a fully
international game we are in many many
many different regions meaning we are
adding the complexity of culture and
different languages for any of our data
science problems that we would be
solving in addition each region like
Europe North America Latin America Korea
is on a completely different set of
servers which means that the community
and the style of play develops
independently within those individual
regions and then there's the numbers
themselves in terms of the players so we
have over 100 million monthly active
players over 500 billion data points per
day and petabytes and petabytes of data
so for those of you who are data
practitioners you can start to see what
all of this intricacy and complexity can
present in terms of not just things that
would be difficult to solve but they're
really giant opportunity space
for the world of data science so how do
we make decisions within a world of this
scale and this amount of complexity the
first and fundamental rule at Riot Games
is to aspire to be the most player
focused game company in the world and
this may seem like a simple statement
but it is absolutely crucial to every
single decision that we make and it
really helps to simplify how you're
going to be making decisions in terms of
the product and the processes that you
follow you always go back to the
fundamental of is this something that's
going to make the game more fun more
fair that's going to bring value to the
player when you have to think in a way
that focuses on the individual the way
that you decide to do data science
becomes more clear when you decide to
build a model you can choose to
aggregate it at different levels you
could aggregate to the region you could
aggregate by champion choice you could
aggregate by map but if you want to
truly focus on the individual player and
make sure that each individual's
information is being represented and
modeled you need to build your models at
the very granular player level it's the
only way that we've found to account for
all the variability and complexity
within the system there's a couple of
other key points that I want to
highlight in terms of decision-making so
the first is building individual models
to suit the individual needs the second
is to recognize when you have separate
systems so when I mentioned before we
have different regions under which
completely different styles of played
have developed so the Korean player base
might be very different from the North
American player base when you have
variability within a system in a machine
learning model or a data science model
people will often add this as a
different degree of freedom or feature
within the model but it's very important
to recognize when the equation itself
might be completely different for your
different systems
and in those cases you need to build
completely separate models for that use
case one of the key things in all of
industries use cases is segmentation and
audience understanding since we have a
system that is changing rapidly at a
minimum of every two weeks you need an
approach that's dynamic and changing
over time in order to be able to model
and monitor how those changes are
happening over time and the last point I
wanted to highlight is that models need
to function within this constantly
changing space this seems kind of
obvious but it means that you need to
build a model that is extremely robust
so you either need something that does
not vary underneath all of these
changing degrees of freedom or you need
something that is going to be able to
retrain fast enough and adapt with the
other changes in terms of the types of
work that we do at Riot Games they fall
into three buckets the first would be
deduction this is where you're solving
problems of identification so is this
someone who's trying to bring fraud or
hacking into the game is this someone
who is of this particular rank is this
someone who would like to play this
champion being able to identify the
differences within the system it also
allows you to explain the systems and
suggest action the second type of bucket
would be under personalization when you
have all of this variability to present
to players each individual has different
kinds of experiences that they want to
have and you can use automated machine
learning techniques in order to provide
us an environment that is more
personalized and the last is
optimization since we have a system
where you have players playing against
other players you have lag time
everything is running live you need to
think about how to optimize those
systems so that you can present the best
experience that you can finally I wanted
to talk a little bit about the data
science skills that come into play
Gamze this is not exhaustive and each
individual person doesn't need to know
all of these but you do need to build a
team that spans across this range of
knowledge so that you can solve the the
huge range of problems that are going to
be presented to you on a day to day
basis in terms of our stack we use a
pretty common stack we use Python of
course every single day or PI spark we
also use R for some of our modeling we
work on the data bricks platform right
games is an AWS or Amazon Web Services
shop and when we're doing business
visualizations and business analytics we
work with tableau so now I'll jump into
the fun stuff which is some of the
actual use cases that we've done at Riot
Games again this is not an exhaustive
list there is so much opportunity in the
space I'm not even going to mention
eSports info sack content none of that
is going to be necessarily what I'm
going to be talking about but there are
just massive spaces for this so the
first and a fundamental one is
understanding positional play so this is
another view of that map that I showed
before which has one lane across the
middle and two lanes across the side on
the top and on the bottom when a player
decides to join a game they join a
system where they're looking for a team
to be built for them so in this case
maybe someone said that they wanted to
play the middle position we will
automatically match them with the rest
of their team so that they find a
complete team composition when you do
that you need that assignment to be done
accurately and fast people don't want to
wait longer than 15 30 seconds to get
their team assignments so that they can
jump in and actually start playing the
game another point is we can
automatically detect how positions are
being used within the game so we can see
if we assign someone a particular
position do they follow through with
using that position how do they play
with it within the game
do they stay within their lane do they
move around what are the mechanics of
the game and how are they changing this
helps us understand how our systems are
actually interacting and determining
play it allows us to track changes or
overtime and understand one of our key
concepts which is the meta or the game
mechanics that one would use another
point and this one might have popped
into your head as an obvious one which
is champion recommendations when you
have so many to pick from and each one
is an individual different play style
recommendations come to mind so we have
a champion recommendation engine that
allows us to understand how play Styles
evolve and how they change over time we
can see what champions are grouped
together and which ones are unique play
styles we use it to better recommend
some champions for the new player
experience so when you jump in and you
start doing a tutorial there's
particular ones that we might recommend
it also allows us to build
recommendations into our store and we
use years and years of new player data
in order to model the cold start plot
problem and use tagging for new content
or champion cold starts ultimately it
allows us to build and recommend content
to players that they're going to get
extremely excited about so I didn't make
this Jeff we found it on reddit but so
this is when we give a couple of times a
year we give our players personalized
recommendations and put discount them
and they get really excited about that
if we give them a good match so finally
one of the fundamental use cases that
you see across the industry is player
segmentation and we have a lot of
different audience types within our game
the biggest and most well-known is being
part of our ranked system this is where
you grow in your champion mastery and
competitively play against other high
mastery players so in this case you can
grow from bronze to
silver to gold and ultimately to
Challenger and I've played against some
of the players that are up at the very
top and they are super humans another
way that you can play is socially you
just want to come in hang out with your
friends spend some time it's a
completely different experience and then
there's players that kind of make their
own game within the game there's enough
flexibility for that variability to be
winning in there but even though that is
a smaller player base we still need to
make sure that we're serving that very
important player base that we have
within all of these use cases the
fundamental rules of modeling still
apply so you're still have to be very
careful and find a lot of information
within your feature engineering so that
you can accurately represent all of the
variability within your data you need to
account for bias and normalization and
there will always be missing data you
need to control for confounds if in a
particular major release we have new
content a couple of countries go on
vacation maybe we introduce a new map
and we throw in a brand new champion in
one release all of a sudden you have all
of these different confounds within the
system but you still need to be able to
model them and answer questions about
them there's going to be outliers not
just in terms of people who are trying
strange things or scripting but you'll
also have outliers in terms of
experience and you need to understand
what's going there there's always a
danger for overfitting particularly when
you have data at this scale and finally
the most important thing I think when
you're applying data science to business
use cases is adding in subject matter
needs or considerations and in this case
it means that the player experience is
fair and fun so when you're building a
model for gaming you might not want to
use the most optimal or the most
accurate model you would want the model
that provides the best experience to the
entire audience overall so how do you
build a team that actually solve
all of these different problems you need
a lot of different roles you don't just
have data scientists or you don't just
have data engineers so you need a
balanced team where you have data
engineers and architects that are
building the fundamental infrastructure
and allowing you to create solutions
that are high speed and high scale you
have data scientists building the
algorithms and actually designing the
approach for machine learning and AI you
have analysts and a strategy team that
interface with your business users and
answer the broad questions and finally
you have data managers that make sure
that all of this is actually happening
get the resources for the team and
figure out the best product direction
there's also a couple of ways that you
can distribute the team a lot of people
have asked me about embedded versus
centralized teams when you have an
embedded model you take a data
professional and you put them in with a
team that might not be the same skillset
as them so this might be engineering or
product or in our case game design and
they have completely different skill
sets that can complement each other but
in a sense they're coming in as a
representative of the group another way
that you can group your data
professionals is to centralize them and
have them all together in one group and
then operate more like a consulting
model there's a couple of different
things that are modified when you use
these two different types of team
structures mainly your product your
communication and your delivery and what
I've found has happened is when you have
a centralized team it allows you to
build a deeper solution because you have
a lot of different professionals
collaborating with each other and it
also allows you to prioritize across the
entire org and find where the best
opportunities might be in terms of
communication it is absolutely the
difference between success and failure
even though we are working in a
technical space because we are providing
solutions that plug into a lot of
different systems communication is
actually key and finally since delivery
is going to be interfacing with other
external teams
has to be very careful planning another
way is the embedded model where everyone
is directly with the team that they're
going to be working with since you might
have fewer data scientists or you have
limited or siloed expertise --is you
solve what you can and provide value
where it's needed in that particular
team it means you'll always have a
resource available but you might not be
prioritizing across the entire org but
it does mean that communication is easy
and it doesn't mean that delivery can be
more flexible ultimately
I say build what you need these changes
these needs change over time and at riot
we use a mix there's a big central team
that we use to meet the large needs of
League of Legends but then we'll have
particular embedded data scientists
where we know there is going to be a
data need at all times so finally what
are some of the things that I'm looking
to build on at wright games it's really
three big categories the first is
building more on the personalized
experience
there's so much that we can build in
terms of giving players the experience
that they're looking for and making it
specifically cater to their particular
needs and once
the second is full model modeling
coverage of all of our dynamic systems
this is just my big-picture thought of
what all industry needs for any of their
business processes which is a model that
explains the system and helps you make
better decisions about those systems and
for anyone else who's in the room and as
an industry you know that even if you've
been at a company or your company has
been around for a long time
you always need more investments in
speed and scale under the hood and
building infrastructure that can support
all of your different use cases so
that's it thank you very much and I
think I have a little bit of time for
questions feel free to come and talk to
me afterwards we're hiring data
scientists data engineers and data
analysts and thank you very much
[Applause]
there's a couple
I don't know I thought there was going
to be a mic floating around hey hey yeah
thank you I had a question you said that
you try to optimize for user experience
and that would seem kind of hard to
quantify I was wondering what sort of
metrics you used instead of say accuracy
in your models yeah so it really is
about the players engagement with the
features that we put out so you can do
simple statistical testing to see if
someone actually engages with the thing
that you're doing or if they stick
around more and like it
so churn engagement retention are the
basic KPIs that you would look at
at one of the points you just mentioned
that some of the targets for your models
it's building experience that's fun and
fair for the players yes how do you
define fair hmm yeah so this is
something that a lot of different games
build into their matchmaking and it's
having an asset balance so that the
teams have about an equal win prediction
when you create a match so you're trying
to balance your matchmaking so that they
have a balanced game one that's fair
where one isn't very very slated to win
out over the other one and they would
just stomp them does that make sense
yeah
good morning morning how do you handle
the the the ownership between the people
who own the data which I assume is a
very technical thing and they have their
own area of expertise and then you build
your models and you have to pass your
models into production so what's that
whole pipeline look like yeah so it
there's a lot of communication there we
actually start with our game designers
and product and try to see what
experiences and products they're
building what features are they're going
to be releasing and where are the
opportunities for data we know our data
pretty well so we can start to work with
them collaboratively and understand
where we would fit into that space once
that we think there's a good enough fit
we decide to make an investment into the
space and plan out to see if we'll make
it in time for the release a lot of our
data scientists are essentially also
engineers in that they can build some of
the integrations into the systems so
then we just do a project plan just like
you would for any other software team
and build together so that we can get it
out into deployment the deployments vary
depending on the speed and the type of
deployment that you need so you might
build it straight into the software or
you might have something offline that's
running that just gives better
recommendations at some point so you
mentioned about having the approach
between the embedded and centralized
data scientist and you also mentioned
about the importance of communications
can you highlight what is the effective
way to communicate within the team yeah
I think there's a lot of communication
in term that's still growing in the
industry in terms of what value data
science brings since it is a new area
for a lot of industries so people may be
unfamiliar with what the particular use
cases might be and why things that
they've done in the past might not be
like why can't they just keep doing the
things the same way that they've been
doing them in the past so one example is
a customer segmentation that's been
around forever why would you do it using
a machine
learning technique so you need to be
able to explain the value you also need
communication just in terms of project
planning so you can't work in a silo you
must communicate what you're doing why
are you doing it and since it is
partially research why it's going to
take a time investment hi how do you
version your models and your data having
so much data so many models so many
iterations on the models yeah we version
using standard version control like it
for our models and then with our data we
have snapshots but that's something
we're building a more rigorous ego
structure ecosystem around
a lot of what you described today seems
to be kind of after a product release
but does your team involved and like a
be testing and doing stuff in the lead
up to new features especially not not
just in like marketing and sales but
also in game features yeah we have two
teams at Riot Games we have data and
insights the insights team is full of
researchers and business analysts that
do more of the a B testing or the
examination of historical data and then
the research team works with surveys
they'll bring people in to play test
they'll actually ask people do you like
this how do you feel about this that
kind of thing hi so you handle massive
amount of data every day have you ever
run into any issue in terms of data
integrity or quality I'm how if you do
how do you solve them like the missing
data you were mentioning yeah if if
anyone in industry hasn't run into
issues with data quality I would love to
talk to them yeah we do we do have
issues with Tayla data quality things
can drop out the pipeline can suddenly
get stuck or jammed in a way this is
where our data engineers are absolutely
key
they put automated testing monitoring
checks into the system so that we always
know the quality of the data as it's
coming through and it also means that we
have to be very careful at large scale
to try to not miss anything because
every individual person needs to get a
good representation of their outcome
when we give those personalized offers
if they don't match the champions that a
player usually plays we will find out so
data quality is a massive concern but
also investment for us
hi Andrea thanks for the talk this is
great
can you give us a little bit of advice
like it sounded like y'all are dealing
with a ton of models and the first thing
I asked myself was how do you like lower
the cost to maintain a cost for training
models that if they're user specific you
had a hunt like millions of models
potentially also where are you storing
them how are you storing them like at
what point do you make sure that you can
create these models in a cost-effective
way and store them in a cost-effective
way so we don't we don't we actually
don't have millions of bottles we just
have a lot of features in the models
which helps in terms of the different
completely different systems I would say
the biggest ones are our region to
region but we don't have a situation
where we're building millions of models
not yet
hi just a couple of questions first with
the amount of data that you have how do
you go about pulling it in a in a net in
a fashion that's that doesn't take a
long long time so just wait for yeah and
secondly how do you sorry hmm I guess
that's it that one question go ahead
but yeah like in terms of pulling just
massive data it's good fundamentals so
being good at knowing what you're
supposed to do in terms of well-written
sequel queries we use spark just across
the board in terms of doing aggregations
we also have some of our engineers that
work with Scala so leveraging some of
those technologies and grabbing
sub-samples as you explore the data so
that you can start to draw conclusions
before you decide to go all in and do a
massive data pool
yeah those actually can be my second
questions like are you gonna sample that
data just after collecting it or you
just boot forces you sample as you
explore and build and then maybe you'll
build something that covers all of the
data for your final production ization
and that's where the architecture and
the parallelization of of your build
really matters
any more questions
all right thank you
[Applause]